Okay. Welcome back to Gary’s Economics.
Today we are celebrating the four year
anniversary of this channel
by rewatching our very first video
All right, so we're going to put this out
in the middle of July.
I started this channel with my mate
Simran on July 14th,
2020.
And the first video we did on
the channel was basically a video
which explained how the money being
given out by governments during COVID
was going to end up with the rich.
How it was going to lead
to a massive increase in inequality
and how it was going to cause a massive
financial crisis.
You know, back at the time,
at the beginning of COVID,
I became really obsessed with this idea
that COVID was going to cause inequality
and it's going to cause an economic crisis
and I was writing articles for newspapers
and things like this, and
I really wanted to start a YouTube
because I wanted to be like, send
this message directly to ordinary people.
And I used to chat on my school
WhatsApp chat to my friends, like,
I'm getting really pissed off
writing for newspapers
ordinary people are not seeing it.
So I want to start YouTube.
But you know,
I don't know anything about videos.
So I was really lucky.
A friend of mine called Simran messaged
me and said, you know, I've got a camera.
Just come to my place and we’ll
shoot a video and start a YouTube channel.
So that was four years ago.
We made this video
and I thought for the four year
anniversary of the channel,
it'd be nice to go through it.
I still remain convinced that this money
given out during COVID is what's driven
the fall in living standards.
And I talk about it
a lot in a lot of my videos.
The government's given out £900
billion, it’s ended up with the rich.
That's increasing inequality.
And people sometimes ask you know,
how did that money end up with the rich?
And obviously,
people who have come to the channel more
recently, haven't seen the first video.
So I thought it would be nice
for the four year anniversary
to do something a little bit different
and to go through together
that first video on
the channel. So you can see
how the channel started off.
The predictions I made back
then at the beginning of COVID.
And yeah, have a bit fun as well.
So let's get started.
Let's watch this video.
This video is about coronavirus and money.
Now, this is a really important video
I've been wanting to make it
for a long time because
huge, huge, historic things are happening
in the world of money.
So this is the opening of the video.
We're really lucky
Simran had like a big white wall
behind him in his in his front room
which we could shoot in front of.
And we wanted to shoot there
so we could do some animations,
which we’ll see the animations come in.
First thing is, we messed
the audio up really badly.
We forgot to turn the lav mic on.
So this is just camera only audio.
You can see
the audio quality is quite bad.
Secondly, you can tell I'm
really pumped up and excited
because I'm talking a little bit
more ghetto than usual,
which is which is what happens
when I get very emotional
When I was working as a money trader
in the 2008 crisis,
nothing ever happened of this speed.
That's me just very briefly mentioning
I was a trader.
I actually wanted to do this whole video
without talking about that.
So we'll see if I mention it again.
What’s happening in the world of money
here is going to dominate the economy
for the next few years,
quite possibly within a few decades.
It's going to affect you, going to affect
your family's financial position.
So if you want to understand
what's going to happen in the economy
going forward, you gotta watch this video.
people complained a lot
that I was clapping my hands too much.
I was emotional.
Now, so far in this crisis.
Most workers have had their incomes
relatively protected.
In this country,
the UK. Most workers are still working
and getting their regular incomes.
Of those who can't work.
The majority are being supported
by government
furlough and self-employment schemes.
Now, as many as five
and a half million workers are falling
through the gaps of those schemes
and are getting almost no income support.
Now, those guys already are feeling
the pain of this financial crisis.
But what we're going to explain in
this video is how
even if your income is being supported,
the change in the world of money
behind the scenes are going to affect
your financial position going forward.
Man I'm talking really quickly,
this video,
I think I was erm,
I had a lot I wanted to say.
I was really
worried about what was going to happen
with this money,
where it's going to end up
and this funny thing happens where
you've kind of semi scripted
the video in your head
and you’re just trying to get out
really, really quickly.
But yeah, just to make the ideas clear,
you know, we knew government's
going to give a ton of money out
and my background
is and was as an inequality economist.
So I really wanted to know who's
going to end up with that money.
And we're going to go
through the logic of it.
Now the biggest changes
have been happening
in the world of government
and central banks.
couple of good photographs there.
That I went and took for the video
Now, this is happening all over the world.
But in the UK, the central bank,
the Bank of England
has committed to printing £300 billion
So that was the initial amount.
That was the initial amount.
I think something happened
which confused a lot of people here,
which was governments
ran a £300 billion deficit,
which means governments gave out
£300 billion UK government
and at the same time the central bank,
the Bank of England did 300 billion QE.
I think these numbers
get confused a little bit.
The best way to
understand it is that the central bank
printed 300 billion.
They gave it to the government
and the government gave it out.
There's two separate
numbers here, which is the amount
of quantitative easing,
which is the amount of money
printed by the central bank and given
to the government and the deficit.
I think the deficit is more important.
But at this point
the two numbers were the same.
So that 300 billion, if we consider
the deficit, is now 900 billion,
it ended up being much, much more.
But the beginning of COVID,
we knew 300 billion
was the amount that we knew at the time.
£300 billion.
It's an enormous amount of money.
It is a massive amount
It's four and a half thousand pounds
for every single man, woman
and child in the country.
900 billion is obviously three times that.
It's more than three times the net worth
of Jeff Bezos, the world's richest man.
Just to clear things up a little bit.
That three and a half thousand pounds
is man, woman and child.
Recently, I use more amount per adult.
So 900 billion, which is the current
amount, is about £19,000 per adult.
That's the total government deficit
since the beginning of COVID.
Now, when such a huge amount of money,
gets printed and put into the economy,
its really important
we understand three things about it.
One, how does it work?
So we're going to talk about
exactly what money printing is.
Where does the money go?
And three, where does the money end up?
Now, those last two things,
they may sound similar,
but they're actually crucially different.
I'm going to explain why Okay.
So number one,
how does this new money work?
So I think a lot of people are confused
by the concept of money printing.
It's important to understand
that this £300 billion is brand new money
created by the central bank.
Now, if that's confusing to you,
you just need to understand
that the central bank has the legal right
to print or create brand new money.
Now we say print money to
give the visual idea of a printing press
printing out new banknotes.
But in reality, nowadays,
most money is electronic.
So what that means in practice
is that the Bank of England is allowed
to simply credit its own account
with new money.
Some good visuals there.
Again,
this is a slightly confusing idea here,
which is first the central bank prints it,
then the central bank
lend it to government,
then the government gives it out.
Since this video, the picture
has been complicated a little bit
by the fact that
government deficits now.
So money which government gives out above
and beyond taxation,
is no longer funded by printing.
So the initial COVID government deficits
were essentially funded by printing money.
But since then it's largely been funded
by borrowing money from the rich.
In both cases, somebody gets richer.
If I print money and give it to society,
somebody gets richer.
If I borrow money and give it to society,
somebody gets richer as well.
I think the best way to understand
it is Imagine you have £100
and I borrowed £100 from you,
so now I owe you £100.
And then I give
the hundred pounds back to you,
but not as a repayment of the debt,
just as a gift.
You now have £100 and your owed £100,
so you get rich either way.
So there's two kinds of government
deficit here
which sometimes confuse people a bit.
One is funded by
central bank
printing, one is funded by borrowing.
But in both cases, the government gets
poorer and somebody somewhere gets richer.
And further into this video we're going
to discuss who it is who gets richer.
Okay, so this is brand new money.
It doesn't come from anyone.
It's not raised through taxes.
It's simply
created by the Bank of England.
When that money gets poured
into the system, we need to understand
who's going to get it.
And the next question.
Where does it go?
this, you know,
this is a really good analysis
by young Gary.
You know,
I was amazed at the beginning of COVID.
We knew enormous amounts of money
were going to be poured into the economy
by the government.
We knew
the government would be impoverished.
We knew somebody would get richer.
I was amazed, and I still am amazed today
how little discussion
there was at the time
and how little discussion has been since
of who has gotten richer
as a result of those deficits.
So the young Gary
is asking the right question.
Now, most of this money is getting lent
from the Bank of England
to the government.
Now, even though this is brand
newly created money
and the Bank of England is a government
institution,
the government still has to borrow it
from the Bank of England.
This creates a debt which legally
the government has to pay back.
and we're still talking about that
government debt today.
Obviously,
it's affecting government spending.
So this reason government
debt has increased hugely already
in this crisis and just recently UK
government debt has gone above 100% of GDP
for the first time in over 50 years.
That was partially
because GDP fell because of COVID. But
government debt
is still so much, much higher than it was
before COVID.
So what does the government then
do with this money?
Well, the government gives most of it
to furloughed workers and other workers
who can't get their income
during the coronavirus crisis.
This brings us to part three.
Where does the money end up?
Now we know the money is being paid
to furloughed workers.
But if we look at the actual situation
of furloughed workers,
they're actually receiving less income
than they were before the crisis happened.
This is really, really important.
People still to
this day will post my videos
and say all of that money
the government gave out,
it went to nurses,
it went to furloughed workers.
It went to, you know,
how can you criticize that?
It's the furloughed workers.
But the money went in the first case
to the furloughed workers.
But furloughed workers
don't get richer, right?
This is the thing that
I was really thinking
a lot about early COVID.
So, yes.
And I think I'll probably say this
in a video. Yes.
The furloughed workers
get the money in the first instance,
but they’re
not the people who end up getting richer.
This is because even though
they're receiving government
income support,
it's only 80% of their original wages
and their original wages
are no longer coming in.
So this creates a mystery.
We know that a lot of new money
is coming into the economy,
and we know that ultimately it's
going to the furloughed workers.
But the furloughed workers
are no richer than they were before.
So where's the money going?
Good analysis.
Good. It's a good question.
That brings us to question number three.
Where does the money end up?
Now we know the money is being paid
to the furloughed workers,
but the furloughed workers
have less money than they had
before the coronavirus crisis
because they've lost the wages
that they were originally being paid.
If we want to know
who ends up with the money,
we need to find out who has those wages.
Where have the wages gone
that used to be paid to the workers.
So if you want to understand,
we have to follow this cash flow back
through the system.
Now, normally wages get paid
to the workers through the companies.
But if we took the companies,
we'll find that most of these companies
are struggling as well,
because customers have simply stopped
coming to their stores
and stopped buying their stuff.
So we need to follow the cash flow back
one step further to the customers.
Now, the customers in this crisis
have dropped their spending massively
So this is a good analysis, right?
The money,
the furloughed money goes to workers,
but they’re not getting richer
because they're not getting their wages.
So who has the wages?
The companies that employ them.
So are the companies getting richer?
No, they're not
because they've been shut down.
So they're no longer
getting their normal revenues.
So who has the revenues
that used to go to the companies
that used to pay the wages or the photo,
the workers?
That's the customers.
This is really, this is really good logic
and it really explains
how the the end
benefitors of the COVID deficit
and the deficits we’ve had
since are ultimately the customers.
For that reason.
Many of these customers
are holding more money in their pockets.
That money is not going to the companies,
which means the wages have stopped.
So the people who are holding more money,
the net benefitors
of the new money being put into
the system are actually the customers.
Now, when I say that,
you're probably thinking,
wait a minute, I'm a customer.
Where's my £4,500
per man, woman and child?
And that would be a good question.
The reason why you might not be holding
£4,500 more than you were before
is because not
all customers are created equal.
Remember
the reason that customers have more money
now than they had before the crisis
is because they've cut their spending.
But it's not all spending
that has cut here.
Spending on essentials
such as rent, mortgage, food and bills
still has to be paid.
So if most of your spending
is on those essentials,
you're spending won’t have fallen by much.
The spending that has fallen
is on non-essentials and luxuries.
So see here, the customers
who are saving the most money...
I pull a really great pose there
when I say, “see here”...
Again, this is good analysis, right?
Customers save money,
but it's not all customers
because ordinary families
are still spending
just like they were before.
It's only richer people
who have a lot of luxury spending,
their spending collapsed during COVID.
So these are the guys that accumulated
the money are the ones who have very high
spending on non-essentials and luxuries.
Well, you're probably starting
to see where I'm going with this.
Who spends a lot of money on luxuries.
The customers who are accumulating money
during this crisis are the rich.
This is a good conclusion,
correct conclusion.
Good analysis.
Now, I wrote an article
predicting this back in March
explaining how rich people,
because they would cut
their spending, would accumulate savings
and money during this crisis.
Gary’s
that proudly predicted it in advance.
Since then, data
has come out from a lot of institutions,
including the IPPR in the UK,
demonstrating clearly that rich people
have been accumulating money
during this crisis because their spending
has reduced so much.
There’s a good story here.
I wrote this article for a website
called openDemocracy
in March 2020, and then I wrote
for The Guardian shortly afterwards.
And somebody from the IPPR contacting me
saying, oh that's interesting.
And I was like screaming at her,
“why aren’t you guys doing this analysis?”
How could you allow the government
to give out £300 billion
and not do any analysis
of where the money is ending up.
So I haven’t mentioned in the video.
But the reason the IPPR did that
analysis was because of my first article.
It's interesting to compare the situation
of a furloughed worker
with a richer person in the economy.
Furloughed workers have lost their income,
which comes from services jobs,
but they've kept most of their spending,
which is largely on essentials
like rent and bills.
Richer workers who tend to work in office
jobs and can work from home
have kept their incomes.
Whereas their spending, which is largely
on luxuries, has collapsed.
That's quite interesting.
Everybody thinks the furloughed workers
are getting the money,
but if you look at furloughed workers,
they're poorer than they were before.
The people who are actually getting richer
are rich people
because they've kept their income,
lost their expenditure.
And nobody was saying this
at the time, really.
And I think even now,
there's not really enough discussion
of, you know, how much richer
rich people got during that period.
It's important to understand
the significance it has on the economy,
when the rich people stop spending.
Now, in normal times,
rich people have very high spending much
higher than ordinary workers,
because that spending goes to companies
which employ workers.
It contributes to wages being paid.
This is really important
because ordinary workers
have to pay bills, rent, food.
When they pay that money,
a lot of that money ends up
going to the owners of the houses
and owners of the corporations
who are themselves, the rich.
Owners of the mortgages as well.
Some good,
some good
animations, some good animation work
there from Simran.
We actually stopped doing animations
after this video because they increase
the time it took us to make
the videos so much, but they are good.
I’d love to do more.
If we had like, if we had more money
to put in the channel,
we would do more animation on the videos.
So as you can see in this diagram,
in a normal situation,
the spending of the rich goes
to the workers.
And when the workers pay their rent,
bills and food, it goes back to the rich.
Some good class analysis there.
The money flows around in a circle.
So what happens when the rich suddenly
stop spending?
Well, that money was driving the wages
for ordinary workers.
Suddenly,
the workers wages have disappeared,
but they still have to pay the rent.
They have to pay the mortgage.
They still have to pay the bills.
How are they going to do that
with no income?
It's a massive problem.
And if nothing happens, some of these
guys, they could become homeless.
They could even
not even get food on the table.
So it's no surprise
that in this emergency situation,
the government and the Bank of England
stepped in with the furlough scheme.
This provides a substitute
income to ordinary workers
who have lost their wages.
It's important to realize that
at this point, from the perspective
of the worker, things actually
look quite similar to pre-crisis.
They've got income,
they've got their expenditure,
their incomes a little bit less.
They have to save a little bit.
But from their perspective,
the situation is largely unchanged.
But look at what is happening
outside of the system.
It's really interesting.
You're
an ordinary worker, you've lost your wage,
but you're getting this money
from the government.
You just think everything's
kind of the same.
You lost one income,
you gained another income.
But the money, government money
is flowing through workers to the rich
and government is accumulating debt
and and the rich are accumulating money.
It's kind of like a massive money
laundering scheme.
Where the government is
just, money is funneled
from the government
to the rich through ordinary workers.
And nobody, ordinary people
didn't realize it was happening.
Kind of crazy.
And it was obvious once you did this
analysis and it's amazing nobody did it.
That behind the scenes,
inequality would be increasing
enormously during that period.
Previously,
the money was going round in a circle.
What's happening now?
The money gets printed
by the Bank of England.
It goes to the worker.
The worker pays their bills.
It goes to the rich. And then
it just stays
there because the rich
are not spending their money anymore.
I must have said the wrong word there
and we tried to overdub it.
It sounds ridiculous, but we did our best.
That means money piles up
with the rich and accumulates.
And what happens with the government?
They accumulate debt.
This is such an important thing
to understand.
Such an important thing to understand.
During COVID, the government
accumulated an enormous amount of debt
and the rich have the income
on the other side of that.
We often talk about the debt
as if it's just, you know, like a
it's kind of a conceptual evil of
the debt is owed to the rich.
The government debt has increased
in proportion to the cash holdings
by the rich.
Okay.
So we've learned that
during the COVID crisis,
most people's financial situation
appears relatively unchanged.
However, behind the scenes,
the government is accumulating
big piles of debt and the rich
are accumulating big piles of money.
The next question is
why does that matter?
Well, the easier part of that question
is to talk about why big government debt
could affect you.
Those of you
who are old enough to remember 2008
will remember at that time
too, government debt increased
and the government came in
and used that to enforce austerity.
My favorite guys, David
Cameron, George Osborne.
Now, that impacted a lot of people.
It had a lot of effects in many,
many different ways
that could happen again
if government debt increased again.
It's a good prediction.
Government debt has increased massively
and now we're in a situation where,
you know, increasingly having austerity
forced upon us
because the government basically
gave a ton of money to rich people.
Now, I'm not a politician.
I'm not a political forecaster.
I'm an economic forecaster.
I can't tell you
if austerity will happen again.
It is happening again.
But what I want to talk about
is those big piles of money
stacking up in rich people's
bank accounts.
It's a good question
because everybody talks about the increase
in government debt, but nobody ever talks
about this massive increase
in cash accumulation by the rich,
which I think is arguably more
important and more damaging.
How is that going to affect you?
So what does it mean
if the rich get richer?
I mean, if they just stack the money
in their bank account,
it's probably not a problem right?
Personally, I worked in the finance
industry for a long time.
I managed money for the rich.
I got involved in understanding
how they invest their money.
Through that, I made some money myself.
I got involved in investing myself.
I know a little bit about what
the rich do when money starts
piling up in their bank account.
so I didn't mention I was a trader.
Number one, they buy houses.
But it's not just houses they buy.
I want to be clear at this point in time,
The Guardian were predicting
and a lot of the media predicting that
because of the weak economy,
house prices would collapse.
So this is a very good prediction
because house prices
have gone up a lot since July 2020.
When this came out.
They buy stocks.
They buy shares. They buy bonds.
Stock prices are an all time high
in basically every country in the world
again, Gold prices
hit a new all time high.
I actually put a massive
bet specifically on the gold price
a few months before this video.
I bought gold, at I think 1470
or 1460 an ounce and it's 2300 now.
It's gone up massively.
What's that like, 60, 70%?
To be honest, they buy everything.
Now, let's look at what happened last time
the government used money
printing to solve a financial crisis.
We can look back to the 2008 crisis.
In many ways that was similar.
That time too, the Bank of England
printed a huge amount of money
to try and deal with an economic crisis.
What happened then?
Well, within six years,
stock prices in London had doubled.
It’s happened again.
Within three years, the gold price was up
150%.
It's not quite 150, but it's gone up
well in pounds, maybe 70, 80%.
These are very good predictions
and very monetizable predictions.
You know, it’s not easy to do that.
And within ten years of the crisis, London
house prices had doubled.
That will happen again.
What does that mean?
Well, in the 20 years since 2000,
through that period of crisis
and rising house prices,
the percentage of young people
who've been able
to afford a home in
this country has fallen from 65 to 27%.
That will continue to fall, definitely.
What will it mean
if house prices double again?
It will mean that realistically,
people who are from a family
that doesn't have a home now
will probably never own housing.
This is obviously continuing to happen.
It means that those people will be locked
out of the housing market forever.
It means that young people
find it more difficult
to get the security
of a home, to raise a family.
And at the same
time as that is happening,
stock prices are going to go up.
Gold prices are going to go up.
The rich are going to get richer than ever
before.
I don't want to big myself up
too much here, but
nobody was saying
these things at the time.
And this is a succession of extremely
accurate predictions made four years ago
But it's not just stocks and shares and
housing that these guys are going to buy.
They'll be in the shops too,
and they’ll have a lot more money
to push those prices up.
I don't think I need to comment
on the accuracy of that prediction.
It's very likely that over
the next few years,
we're going to see the prices
of a lot of things increase.
He's pretty good.
He's pretty good this guy.
At the same time,
what's going to happen to wages?
Well, we've already seen the unemployment
rate double in this country,
This is the first prediction.
I've watched this before.
This is the only prediction
which was not really accurate
in this video and we'll talk about it.
and that's in spite of a furlough scheme
encouraging firms to keep jobs on.
There's currently 9 million workers
on that furlough scheme.
And when that starts to be wrapped up,
a lot of those workers
will probably be pushed into unemployment.
So at the time I made these,
people will not remember this now.
At the time
I made this video in summer 2020.
The furlough scheme was due to end
before lockdown ended, which
was obviously an insane policy.
And what you kind of see here
is my naivete as an economic forecaster
rather than a political forecaster.
It probably should have been obvious
at the time that they would have
had to extend furlough,
but I've just got my kind of economics
maths brain on, which is
if you end furlough before you end
lockdown, you're going to see
a massive spike in unemployment.
But of course, we know now in hindsight,
furlough was extended for years,
which at the time people
people didn’t know it was going to happen.
But clearly, I didn't anticipate that
With unemployment going up and up and up.
It's very likely that just as house
prices and prices in the shops are rising,
wages will stay low.
I mean, that's pretty consistent.
You know, wages have definitely not kept
track with shop prices or house prices.
That’s definitely correct.
Okay, so what can we do?
We know that under the current situation,
the rich are going to get richer
while wages fall, house prices
rise and shop prices increase.
It's going to make housing unaffordable
and it's going to drop living conditions
for regular people.
it's bad grammar, drop living conditions.
It's a big problem of mine, bad grammar.
Well, personally, I think that it can
if you go back and look at this slide
explaining the problem.
We can see what's happened.
Money currently is flowing
from the government to the rich,
leaving government with big piles of debt
and the rich with big piles of money.
We can actually fix this
with one single arrow in this diagram.
If we start money moving
back around the system away from the rich,
no more cash piles to the rich.
No more debt for the government.
In my opinion, we need to find ways to tax
the truly rich in our society
by taxing wealth rather than just income.
It's good analysis and it's amazing
fewer people are making this point.
You know, in the last five years,
the wealth of the richest has exploded,
Government debt has exploded
as a pretty obvious result of
these furlough and these COVID policies.
You can reverse that if you tax the rich.
You know, it's amazing that
we don't do it.
And here you see me
just trying to make it clear
when I say we tax
the rich, we're not talking about
necessarily high wage earners.
We're talking
about extremely wealthy families,
which is something
I continue to say to this day.
This will draw money
from the wealthiest people in our society,
the people who get their income
from owning assets rather than working.
Ultimately, we need to find a way
to make the richest in our society
contribute to fixing this crisis
rather than simply profiting from it.
Otherwise, financial security
is going to move
out of the reach of our kids.
Thank you for watching.
This is a message
which is really important to me.
If you think it's important too, share
with your friends, share with your family.
If you want to know more about me,
you can see my Twitter
and my website in the description.
Come back for more videos.
Okay.
Thanks again.
Me trying to figure out what to say
at the end of the video.
You know, it's a really good video.
I'm glad we’ve gone through it,
because I know
obviously
at the time we made this video, we,
it's the first video on the channel,
so obviously we didn't have no followers.
We probably got like
a couple of thousand views,
which is mainly our friends
and our friends of friends.
You got 60,000 views on it now,
but obviously the channel
has grown massively,
especially in the last sort of six months,
and a lot of new people
won't have seen it. So,
you know, my
background is as an inequality economist
and I made a lot of money betting that
inequality will damage living standards
in the last five years and see the biggest
and fastest increase in inequality
in the history of the Western world
and I believe it’s driving
living standards down.
It's a powerful video.
You know, even now, five years later,
I think the predictions are really good.
It's not easy to make good predictions
like that. So,
yeah, you know, watch it, understand
it, share it,
but more importantly, understand that
inequality is hurting living standards
and it's not going to get any better.
It's going to keep getting worse.
Hopefully our videos
have gotten a little bit better
in terms of professionality.
And I think maybe some people
question that.
But more than anything,
the channel is growing a lot
and we're really reaching of people.
And that's thanks to all the people who've
been watching all of these four years.
Unfortunately,
inequality has continued to get worse
and worse and it's not getting any better.
But thanks to the work of people like you
who been watching
throughout the years,
we managed to educate more and more people
that it's a problem.
And hopefully
if you keep teaching people,
we can eventually reach the politicians
and we can force them
to reverse this growth in inequality.
And if we do that,
then we can improve living standards
and we can stop seeing this
dreadful increase in poverty.
I want it to change.
I've been doing it for four years now.
I'm going to keep doing it.
And thanks for your support.
And let’s try and make things better. Tax
the rich.
Reduce
inequality. Save the future. Thank you